well i mean even my mother as a child
mark my mother told me if you want to be
a whole be a good hoe
if you're going to be anything be the
best at it and that's what i tried to do
all right jazzy hey jesse oh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally i
am originally from flint michigan
i left flint michigan and moved to new
york city at around
18 or 19 and stayed there for 17 years
and then i left flint i mean i left new
york and i met up with pimp and ken
and we went all across the south and um
i learned the game and that's that's how
i got my introduction
that's how i came into the game let's go
back to your family you had
both parents growing up i did my mother
was very masonic
she was a eastern star uh my grandmother
and grandfather were very masonic my
grandfather was very masonic so they
were all into like
that whole world what is masonic well
they're
very uh very spiritual uh
some may call it satanic i'm not on that
side even though my family was very
um eastern stylish and masonic and
templation i was
i do remember taking uh oaths and
pledges when i was younger
because that's what my family was and
that's what they were about excuse my
hands was a little ass
but that's what they were about and um
yeah i'm on a different side of the
fence right now
and how was your childhood i had a
wonderful childhood my mother worked 32
years
and general motors i didn't want for
anything my father owned his own
construction company so
i was a very spoiled little girl i had
everything i wanted growing up i mean i
didn't have a perfect childhood my
mother died when she was
when i was 15. so i was on my own after
that
you know i had to take care of myself
flint michigan is very
uh it's about to happen to have nots you
know i've been hearing a lot lately
where people
are they put black people like
light-skinned against dark skinned and
that type of [ __ ]
growing up it was about to happen to
have-nots so either you had it or you
didn't i don't give a damn if it was
light
bright white uh disappearing you could
have been a geico blended in with the
grass i don't give a [ __ ] if you didn't
have no money
or you didn't have things you know
people didn't want to [ __ ] with you so i
kind of made a name for myself growing
up
i was very popular um amongst my peers
and you know i grew up having things and
even after my mother died
i got into the game a little bit because
i had to maintain i had an apartment at
15.
so i had to maintain that lifestyle it
was about like i said to having to have
nots it wasn't about light-skinned
doctors that's a stupid [ __ ] argument
mike i just want to let you know
if you ever hear black folks arguing
about who's light and who's dark
that's a stupid pole [ __ ] argument okay
because people when you have you don't
you know not saying i have a lot you
know but i grew up
not wanting for anything so yeah i had a
good childhood but after your mom after
you lost your mom
after i lost my mother you think you got
hired it got rough
because that was my mother you know no
matter what we went through
or or what i what what things i dealt
with i mean there was some abuse growing
up and because i was adopted
i was adopted at birth um but
yeah i i didn't want for [ __ ] and i and
i learned a lot from seeing the black
women that i saw
they all worked they had husbands who
was you know who equal were equally
yoked
everybody had money everybody lived a
lifestyle so i didn't see
i mean the things i see in here now uh
yeah i wasn't i didn't see that growing
up i mean now i see a lot of [ __ ] hell
i'm not i can't even live up to the
[ __ ] that i saw so
um but so the the game how my titties
look
you look amazing darling absolutely from
head to toe
um so you got into the game at what age
roughly
i would say about 15 on my own but a
real introduction
where i really learned the game okay
when i moved to new york
i worked in a a whorehouse that was
owned by the
italians it was owned by the mafia and
it was only like two black girls working
out a
bevy of whitehole so i worked there for
a little while
and then i met up with pimpin ken
because he knew my first
baby's daddy as we said he knew my first
baby's father
uh who was was a well-known rapper on a
major label not
no underground he's well known and um
i got introduced to pimping ken um and
i'm not saying he was a pimp or not
that's all allegedly mark
i'm not saying he was a pimp because
when i met him the i mean all this man
did was read he wanted me to read he was
very
very intelligent so this is a shout out
to ken i'm not trying to
disrespect your name love you are a king
indeed
salute to you he taught me a lot um
we went all across the south and he just
wanted me to learn the ends in and
out so your experience with gentlemen
that do that kind of work has been very
positive
very positive very he never laid a hand
on me
and then you know of course i i you know
i don't know if i said this in the
beginning but after i met him
i went to milwaukee and i met the love
of my life pimp snooki
who i have a daughter with superior hi
tim snooki
i love you um who's in prison right now
he's in prison right now freda king
and no i don't i mean i have experiences
as we all do but mostly positive i mean
these men should
show me how to get money i mean nowadays
like i see your show mark i see your
show
i see the caliber of people you know and
and a lot of them
uh don't look like they got a pocket
pissing or a window to throw it out and
it's like
every guy that i dealt with they all had
money and they all knew how to get money
it's like how can you teach somebody
how to get money if you've never had
money well i think i think i have a full
range
yeah you have had a few you've had
you've had the bishop on here
salute you've had i mean a lot of guys
uh have because we both from flint
michigan
kenny red sharp mr seymour you got to
get world famous play you got to get
juju on here because he is spectacular
juju i love you salute to you
but yeah just back i'm just waiting for
snooki to get out of prison we're
waiting on snooki to get out of prison
because he is a
uh he is a spectacular man yes he is and
he taught me a lot
and i want to apologize to snooki on
camera on your show if that's okay
because i may have said things in the
past on the
line or because you know things get
around online and i want to apologize to
that king i am really sorry
uh for anything negative that i had that
i may have put out there
against your name because i didn't mean
it you are spectacular
we have a beautiful daughter together
and you were a blessing and you taught
me a lot
so i'm grateful for that i am grateful
for that more it was more good than it
was
so for you the game was it sounds like
it's different than what it is for a lot
of the people i've interviewed which is
about drugs and about
you know yeah i wasn't allowed to do
drugs i wasn't allowed when we
when i had a pimp which was only one
that i'm gonna say i mean
i'm not gonna say that he was that's all
alleged uh when i had
uh snooki when i was with him i wasn't
allowed to do drugs i was rarely allowed
to even drink alcohol
let alone do a drug so i mean because
back then
it's like you know that's a drug dealer
becomes a whole nother pimp i mean
that's cutting into
the money that we're trying to make
we're trying to build i mean this man
owned stores
and uh nightclubs and i mean he he
showed us the world i mean we went all
across country so
it was um it was about more than just um
i would say pimping and hoeing i mean it
was a lifestyle
when we talk about pimping and honey in
the game it's a whole lifestyle it's not
just
uh some man beating up on a [ __ ] and
she's going to give money and bringing
it back
no it's a lifestyle we have family and
we together i mean so well you're you
were playing the game at a very high
level
i i was well i mean even my mother as a
child mark my mother told me if you want
to be a whole be a good hoe
if you're going to be anything be the
best at it and that's what i tried to do
you know i tried to live up to that i
wasn't i wasn't playing for small steak
that's why i went to the
i went to these men i went to ken i went
to snooki and i
and i asked i asked for their help so
that i could learn the game
so that i could be the best me that i
could be
and and make the most money i mean why i
left first of all
let me explain i worked i had a career i
was a hair stylist in brooklyn for like
seven years
i was in hair magazines all doing all
you know all over the place i had a
career i left my career
and said i got to get this hoe and out
of my system so i went
i found these men you know i learned
what i could learn
and and um and and i i did it the best
to my ability so what do you think
about your system as you call it
attracted you to this
you had a job once you turn your first
trick like i said when my mother died
i had to maintain so i kind of dibbled
and dabbled once you turn your your
first
trick you never kind of go back you
never kind of turn back into a complete
square
so even though i went to school i went
to cosmetology school i finished high
school i even went to college
in new york i went to school for filming
television um
it was never out of my system so what do
you make of that that
controversial comment once a whole
always a whole you can't
turn a hole into a housewife well i'm
not gonna say you can't turn a hole into
a housewife you just have a housewife
that's a hoe
you know she got a little whole winner
but you can turn her she can be a
housewife now
you know but she gonna be a housewife
she's gonna be a hoe that's a housewife
that's
all yeah but a good housewife because
everybody the pimp that i had snooki i
mean you had to know how to cook
you had to clean you had to clean your
body and wash your [ __ ] ten times a day
so everything gonna be smelling fresh
the food gonna be good
the house gonna be clean you're gonna
get [ __ ] good and we're gonna make our
own money you know these the type of
hoes i grew up seeing too my mother
worked 32 years
and teased everybody and they all had
husbands who had
equally if not more money than they had
so yeah
i think there's something for everybody
so yeah you can turn a hole into a
housewife but no she you're probably not
going to have the type of
housewife that's going to just sit there
and just be at home waiting on you
no we got to get this money let's turn
this into an empire let's build a
pyramid let's turn this into a legacy
when we die we got statues and people
naming streets after us because
this is what we have planted and this is
the seed that we have left behind you
know so
back to my other question which was what
attracted you to the game
when you were when you already had a
career well i wanted to learn i mean i
was already selling [ __ ] but i was
doing it wrong
so i wanted to learn how to do it right
i mean i worked everywhere from hunts
point mark to chicago
in the wintertime at night i wanted to
learn how to do it right i didn't want
to end up dead
and become just another dead black [ __ ]
i didn't want to be
uh uh have a criminal record which i
don't
okay i see people up here mark and they
have like we've been in jail and we did
you know
you might find my mug shot for those of
you uh that google queen jazzy over here
and follow me on instagram
queenjazzilla you might find my mugshot
but all of them charges was dropped and
that was for assault
and i don't have a criminal record and
never in the gang
ever have i ever had a criminal record
because that's not fly [ __ ]
like we was i was taught by the the men
that i work with
um because i don't want to say pimps
because that's illegal so
um the men that i worked with um that's
not fly [ __ ] so we did everything we
could to not get arrested and the men
that you worked with were the best of
the best
they were the best of the best and they
taught you how not to get arrested they
taught you
how cops speak and they do speak a
certain way so you already know it's a
cobb when they calling you on the phone
or you know when you when you see them
uh
wherever wherever you may be nowadays
because i don't really know what these
the hoes do nowadays but back then i
mean we didn't we weren't limited we
worked wherever we could what kind of
little tricks does a girl need to know
to do this like when you get a guy's car
you got to make sure that door is going
to open from the inside right
you make sure it's going to open from
the end so well how did you know not too
many people work the
the blade now that was back then many
years ago but with a call
service even with as you if you were
there's plenty of girls
working the blade still really i have
been a s i was an escort i worked in
whole houses i worked on the blade i'd
worked in strip clubs so i hadn't done
it all there was nothing
there was nowhere that i had no ground
that i didn't cover
um you just have to listen out for
certain things that they say
if a trick called you and automatically
he offering you say
thousands of dollars without even
knowing you or getting to talk to you or
knowing you
nine times out of ten that's a cop when
you get like if you get in the car with
a guy yes you got to make sure the car
opens from the inside you look in the
back make sure he ain't got nobody
jumping out the back seat
um tell him to go to a spot that you
know
don't let him control it uh just certain
thing you can't let a trick ever control
the situation period
so do did you have any bad experiences
of course i did
when i first got in the game i did get
raped in chicago
uh by a white guy got in the car didn't
check the door like i just told you all
to do
then check the door okay and it was
locked from the inside and then he put a
knife to my head and said you you i'm a
rapist
i'm not a murderer but if you make me i
will kill you
and um at the time i think i might have
been like two months pregnant
okay i don't mean to put that out there
but i am i'm just gonna keep it all away
funky
i was like two months pregnant and i was
working yes i was
and he took me to a warehouse um
and i had to use the the game the little
bit of game that i had had at that time
because i had just got in the game
to finagle my way out of that situation
with my life or my daughter's life i was
unbehaved scarred anything i did get
raped though i did have to go to the
hospital
didn't have no diseases none of that but
i i was
i was alive so that was a bad experience
and i never forgot it and i i paid
attention after that because that
that came from me not really listening
and paying attention to what i was told
so so when you're working with a a man
like pimping ken
or snooki yeah you're bringing him how
much of the money
oh all of it and he does what with that
well i want all that game so you know
you got to give
all the money i don't want half of half
of the knowledge i mean the things that
they taught me i still
live by today so they made sure they
made sure i was taken care of i mean
snooki i mean i had my own house
i traveled across country i i mean i had
everything i needed
there were there were plenty of cars i
mean nobody wanted for anything and i
wasn't the only girl so
yeah nobody wanted for we played to win
we didn't we didn't play to like
it wasn't you know nowadays i hear
stories about girls uh
they it's like 50 of them in one hotel
and they selling [ __ ] to pay for the
room when that [ __ ] is insane
the pimp living in the room with them
they all selling [ __ ] just so they can
pay for
one room at the motel 6 which is forty
dollars at best
so yeah that [ __ ] is insane no we had to
pay for our own roles uh
we went from state to state we had to
make our own way
uh there was a a minimum
of five 500 a day that miss jazzy had to
check in and this was back then
and 500 a day i did uh more than that
but i had to add minimal check that in
every single day
when i was cross-country so that that
was just you know back then i don't know
i see him now i mean it's a little
sloppy it's a black eye on the game
right now i see it now
and i'm not here to downplay anything as
far as
sex trafficking or anything like that
it's all bad if you pimping underage
girls that [ __ ] is all bad and
disgusting but
i'm here on another side of the game you
know i have a
i i don't have a i don't have a really a
bad story yeah
your story i learned a lot i mean i'm
doing very very well right now i just
finished school for accounting well i
got a certificate after i finished the
course okay
let me not big myself up like that but i
mean i am doing great things right now i
overcame a lot
i work two full-time jobs i pay for i
pay my house note every month
my car know my daughter got a new car
that she just totaled so and you're
ready you know
you have how many kids i have two grown
daughters you raised them
i raised them 18 and 29
so two grown daughters one lives in
california the other one is in
uh milwaukee
were drugs ever a part of your life yes
drugs was a part of my after
after i left the pimp and not during i
did get into drugs i started snorting
coke for a long time
while you were working the street no you
were on when i went back to new york
this is after i kind of left the game
but then i got back into it i was
escorting but not i didn't have a pimp
um so you're escorting on your own on my
own this is years later
uh yeah i was going through mental
issues
yeah i went through a lot i had to go in
and out of uh hospitals for
for mental issues and just i mean the
game i guess the game and just growing
up just my
life being targeted and and uh
doing things that i've done it took a
toll on me and it caught up
but i just you know i don't even want to
paint that picture because i was never a
victim but yeah i did
turn the drugs mark i got so bad at one
time i started shooting up
uh slept in a park
but i woke up from that park you know
and i don't i've been clean
two years today i don't so much as drink
alcohol
i don't do any drugs not weed nothing
don't take pills don't take tylenol i
fast
i pray i work two full-time jobs pay my
bills
um and look beautiful all day you sure
do that's what i do
you sure do did you ever get depressed
doing this kind of work
um may i want to say depressed but be
love sick because i was really like i
love i love snooki with all my heart
so back then you know that he was my
first love
and um yeah i didn't know how to
deal with my emotions but i loved him so
yeah i would get love sick
not depressed but love sick like who he
[ __ ] tonight
you know that's goofy [ __ ] but uh
no but i certainly don't get depressed
now and uh
is it possible to have a a real love
relationship while you're doing that
kind of work
for a girl well back then that was a
real love i mean you
and the gentleman that you were uh
breaking bread with that was a real love
relationship because that was our
reality
so it wasn't i mean i wasn't square at
the time so that was what
even though you're having intimate
interactions with
multiple guys every night well i feel
i'm let me clear something
i wasn't i was taught different so i
wasn't a flatback and how i really
didn't
[ __ ] a lot of men i would be lying if i
said i never had sex uh
with any of the guys that i saw but i
didn't fight and do a whole lot of
[ __ ] i mean it was very rare i mean
my customers most of them were white
okay like i hear you ask the questions
you should ask some of these hoes like
what did you prefer you know
i might have been a racist hoe i mean i
liked white men because they spent more
money
and they asked for less activity you
know you see a black man for fifty
dollars he want to [ __ ] you all night
have you upside down
twerking on your head one cheek left
cheek i don't have time for that
i don't want to sweat i don't want to
mess my weave up you know
my eyebrows is perfect i don't want to
do none of that so
you know i saw mostly white men and they
took care of me long after i got out of
the game
so yeah they're treating me more like a
yeah like a queen like a girlfriend
so this kind of work it builds up your
self-esteem or ultimately takes it down
breaks it down i would say a combination
of both but in my case
my self-esteem was already built i mean
my mother and father did a wonderful job
so i'm not going to blame any downfall i
had on the game i mean i went through
a lot in life period that kind of caught
up like my mother's death
she died in front of me my father died
my grandmother everybody
so my brother um a lot of things caught
up with me so i'm not going to
say it was the game the game has been
believe it or not has been sort of a
plus for me because i learned a lot and
it
provided me with a family that will
always be my family you know no matter
what shout out to
uh shamika monet avery just saluting you
queen
um and yeah a family that i always
consider
my family so i don't really have nothing
bad to say about it uh
so looking back at your life do you have
any regrets
[Music]
um maybe exposing my kids to what i was
doing well
at that time i only had one daughter and
um taking my youngest from her father
which was snooki
when she was three months old i regret
to regret that because of whatever me
and him was going through at the time
so i do regret that i do regret certain
things that i had to expose them to
and later on in life believe it or not
you will have to explain to your kids
uh what was going on and um yeah
the situation is at hand so i do regret
exposing my my children to certain
things because i take being a mother
very seriously
what was the best time your life the
beginning when i first met snooki
and being a mother just giving birth to
both of my kids but when i first met
snooki uh
it was just me and him me and him
against the world
there was nothing there was no outside
coming in
there was no nothing it was just me and
him no other girls
it was girls but you know at that time
he made me feel like it was
all about me so at that time that was uh
i would say that moment right there was
was one of the best moments of my life
and then giving birth to my kids not no
particular order for those of y'all
that's gonna say not her kids
no that it wasn't in a particular order
but love is
uh the best time in my life so both of
those situations symbolize just me being
in love
what was the worst time oh my mother's
death
and i just lost the uncle that that took
a lot on me and my father's death yeah
having a d any death having to deal with
somebody i love dying
so so because your game your your
memories of the game or your experience
with it
is so different than everyone else's the
question i ask a lot of the girls is
what is the most misunderstood thing
about this lifestyle and it'd be
interesting to hear your
answer to that question well people
think that the game consists of
some man beating on you all the time and
you giving him all your money and he's
forcing you
to do things when i find i chose i chose
sunuki
like i came to him i literally handed
him a few thousand
dollars and uh i travel i mean not okay
i don't want to because i don't want to
uh
implicate that he was doing anything
illegal this is all allegedly
so but and i was in my 20s i was in my
late 20s i wasn't a young girl
i left new york came to him
and uh it was all by choice so you chose
him i chose him
and you know you had to pay to be part
of his i had to well in the beginning
yeah i had to pay to be a pirate because
they want to know you serious you know
so i got to use that yeah he had already
done
like pimp sub holes down and things like
that so he already had a name
so they want to know that you uh
serious and you are who you say you are
so yeah i had to uh
but i was well in my 20s i was like 27
years old
then even though i look 27 now you do
look 20
24. okay but no i'm not she's not her
daughter's 29
but yeah i was 27 then um so yeah no the
people have misconception that you're
being forced and made to do things when
you're not
when i was tired and ready to go miss
jazzy packed her bags
and left and never returned never
returned
how how is jazzy different after that
those seven years five years
than she was before oh jazzy because
jazzy is over the top
jazzy is over the top i'm very honest
very straight up very uncomfortable
did it make you a little more streetwise
it made me a little it made me a lot
more streetwise
uh very open and honest i have i saw
and i paid attention i paid attention to
everything that i learned
some of the most memorable times was uh
like for
i'm just gonna say this me and snooki
would have these talks in the park
i'm not gonna say what they were about
but it was just so intense and so
just learning and just paying attention
so it has made
me very streetwise 10 steps ahead of
people like 10 steps ahead of the game
i've been able to overcome a lot being
with a pimp like snooki
a man like that really coach it's a life
coach almost
he was a life coach he was he was my
everything
he was my everything and he still is to
a degree to
you know i still listen to him even to
do this interview i asked him if it
would be okay
did you find you got addicted to that
lifestyle i did it is very addictive
mark it is
almost like a drug and i i found myself
i had to go to groups
later i mean because you weren't doing
drugs what is it that's addictive
about it the whole lifestyle the
camaraderie the money
the the the guy i mean the the just
being with the gentleman that i was with
i was addicted to him uh i was addicted
to
the roller coaster relationship that it
was i mean
it's very everything about it is
addictive traveling not have
not having to answer to any i mean well
you had to
i had to answer to somebody but you know
not clocking in
um being your own boss it's kind of
rebellious it's very rebellious
and you feel very free and you know kind
of like a warrior so
and once you've been exposed to it it's
going to be really hard to go back very
hard
it's very hard it's very hard and i
yeah like i said i had to go to a lot of
groups like hi my name is jazzy
not not necessarily about but just talk
about just everything
to kind of distance myself from the
lifestyle and just
kind of be the big old square [ __ ] that
i am right now
a little bit not all the way what's the
most important
thing what's the what have you learned
about human nature
from doing this kind of work um just
that being honest is
is freeing and the most important thing
and family is
everything so just you got to have your
priorities straight i mean a lot of
people think
you know material things are good to
have i mean
but that's a temporary fix you want your
family to be in place you want your kids
to be all right
uh you want to learn from people as much
as you can
so that you can prosper and leave a
legacy behind you know i didn't
i don't want to die and then there's no
legacy for my children or
uh my mama was a whole that's the story
you know that that's my eulogy at my
funeral my mama was a hoe and then they
dropped the mic and walk off the stage
you know
you know i did a lot of things you know
my mommy was a writer
uh she wrote a book stay tuned for my
book okay any publishers out there
satan is a black man that will be about
me and snooki and uh
volunteer slaves my second book so stay
tuned for that
um but yeah i didn't i wanted to leave a
legacy
and and not just you know have my kids
talk about
their mother and their father um in the
game so to speak not that that's a bad
thing because
you know we did all right but that's the
most important thing just being honest
and and living an honest life and uh
trying to do right by people i always
try to even in the game i did right by
people i never tried to step on toes
and that could be why i'm still alive
today
all right jazzy well thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you and i
wish you
the best of luck thank you thank you